so I understand you mentor young people
on becoming directors or actors what are
some of the lessons that you find
yourself repeating most to these people
well I mentor because I believe passing
it forward and I see tragedies a cap
near I see beautiful young girls coming
out here three years later they're
almost unrecognizable young guys coming
out with just dreams and no one's saying
with the business set of all and they
are drugged out or just I don't know
doing crazy stuff
rejection it's a business of rejection
so in my classes that we teach two
things several things we teach the
business of the industry what is the
industry what is distribution what is
financing what is marketing what does a
studio was a network
what is Sag what is AFTRA what's the DGA
what is it business of the industry and
we take financial literacy okay you've
made money right and everybody tells you
to spend it how do you use it how do you
use money teach them that then we teach
them the paradigm shift between that's
happening between film and media also
coming out here or like they want to be
actors and directors and they want to be
Steven Spielberg I say okay it's good
but why not be Steve Jobs to notice the
last name Jobs so
we we really cold-blooded in terms of
then leave the class they love and hate
us because they're they become business
people maybe they they they they they
teach the acting part of it but they
know what a cell phone app is and how to
use it they know what a game is and they
we should start getting you know those
get into gaming not only being in one
but creating one they should really be
getting into creating your own webisodes
I don't know how to write a webisode so
what's that guy's gonna you think write
one what's that what you're not knowing
how to do it what's that got to do what
do you think you if you're serious you
find a way I can point you to a writer
come with a good idea I mean you know
it's like you have to give them you know
you cannot make an informed decision if
you do not have the information to make
it with can't do it it's all guessing
you may guess right but man almost lumps
outside your head my god
you